thank you
in the UK midnight in Kiev you're
watching Sky News at 10 as Ukraine's
president's undefeated country one year
on
commentable the bull zielinski tells his
people as he says Ukraine will win this
year and rejects negotiations with Putin
do you believe that
you're going to have to negotiate maybe
even compromise maybe even talk to
Vladimir Putin
the Russians don't care and seeing the
world this way if you think we're
ukrainians can sit and negotiate with
all of this
we see the war's consequences across
this country and Beyond the hundreds of
thousands or injured
a minute of Silence in memory of the
victims of the aggression
The Diplomatic incident at the U.N is
Russia's Ambassador interrupts an
attempt to hold a silence to remember
the past Year's victims
uh solidarity with Ukraine in the UK as
the prime minister
a minute silence
also on Sky News at 10 tonight how King
Charles was close to be being deployed
by Downing Street in the final push for
a brexit deal over Northern Ireland
I want to prove I am not all Mountain
trousers
so Rod Stewart makes good on the promise
he made on Sky News paying for a day of
scans at his local hospital
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 40.
[Music]
good evening then from there was a mess
science here from president zielinski
today on the bursary of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine he said his people
have all three and defeated do
everything to gain Victory this year and
that won't include negotiations with
Russia kill while Russia kill and
torture he told Sky News in an extended
Sky News at 10 tonight
security editor Deborah Haynes who asked
president that question today reports
from here in Kiev
on Alex in eastern Ukraine looking at
this war is taking we'll get the view
from Russia's home front a year into the
correspondent Diana magnet Siberia and
in New York Mark Stone reports on the
techshi conference to U.N security
Council between Russia and Ukraine but
our first report tonight from
is here in Ukraine one year on
commemoration
not celebration
Ukraine marks one year of War by
honoring those who died to keep this
country free
the president Russia wanted to topple
still in charge
Ukraine
foreign
hurting
but defiant
in the town of butcher where a mass
grave was found the pain runs deep
Russia's brief occupation here has left
permanent scars
this memorial wall in Kiev is a reminder
that Ukraine has actually been under
attack since 2014.
that's when Russia first invaded and
annexed Crimea
it became a frozen Conflict at times all
but forgotten by many in the West
Vladimir Putin changed all that last
year galvanizing allies in a way that
hasn't been seen since the Cold War but
Russia isn't backing down and neither is
Ukraine
despite the security risk the president
gave a live press conference in a sign
of growing confidence
do you believe that Ukraine can achieve
Victory on the battlefield or do you
believe that ultimately you're going to
have to negotiate maybe even compromise
maybe even talk to Vladimir Putin
businesses
foreign
he hopes for victory this year
until then the war will go on each flag
here in the capital is planted in memory
of the Fallen
a growing Garden of grief and sacrifice
well we're going to try and return to
Mark in a short while in the meantime at
least 8 000 civilians have been killed
in the war but that number is dwarfed by
the number of soldiers dead on both
sides the ministry of Defense in the UK
thinks up to 60 000 Russian soldiers
have been killed in a moment we'll see
the impact of that in a part of Siberia
but first our International
correspondent Alex Rossi reports from
the east of the country on the front
line sacrifices made by the Ukrainian
people
in a Windswept graveyard Victoria Mourns
her husband
you are my life you're my heart my Heir
I love you she says
Ruslan was killed a few days ago when he
was hit by a tank round his
three-year-old twins still don't
understand their father is never coming
home
[Music]
um
Ukraine does not disclose figures for
its dead but it is a number that's
Rising fast
and so too is the rate of casualties
at this Rehabilitation Center soldiers
try to overcome their injuries
Oleg was lacerated by shrapnel and
doctors have warned him he may still
lose his limb but despite his sacrifice
he says Russian aggression has only made
this nation stronger
foreign
thoughts would be a lightning Conquest
has morphed into an exhausting Jewel of
artillery
with no end in sight
the fighting here in the donbass over
the last year has been absolutely
Relentless and it appears to be getting
worse in the face of a new Russian
offensive now in places like this
most people have left
and it's easy to understand why every
day now
the artillery is getting closer
in the shattered broken communities of
this region people are weary
shuffling through the cold to fetch Aid
Parcels as the fighting rages around
them
no this is the
um
but after a long year the cost of this
punishing war is increasingly only
measured in pain and suffering
and at the cemetery new plots are being
excavated for soldiers that have not yet
been killed in combat
it is a bleak picture and this of course
is just one military cemetery in a
country which is bleeding for its
survival
Alex Rossi Sky News in the donbass
and the rains is here with me now we saw
you asking that question of President
zielinski earlier what did you make of
his tone and his mood a year into this
war he was confident he was fluent
Fielding multiple questions and he was
defiant but this is a President Who
faces a huge challenge going forward
he's already dealt with the odds and
he's still in post a year on from this
full-scale Invasion the eyes of the
world are on this country today but he
knows full well the war will be
continuing tomorrow his men his women
will need to fight tomorrow the next
eight months possibly even years more
his line is unwavering he will not
compromise he doesn't want Russia to
have any of Ukraine's territory but he
needs his Western backers to stay the
course and Russia isn't changing its
mind either he knows full well there are
hard hard days ahead yep there certainly
are Deborah thank you very much indeed
well the Russian soldiers fighting in
Ukraine are not taken evenly from across
their vast country most are recruited
from poorer regions often far from
Moscow one of those is briatia in the
country's Far East our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet traveled
there to speak to people on Russia's
home front
buriatia feels like it's a world away
from war in Europe it is a different
Russia more like Mongolia next door than
Moscow
but drive a little way from the main
city of Orlando day and you reach this
graveyard where the true cost of the war
is spelled out in funeral garlands and
Military flags and in the faces of men
all killed six time zones away in
Ukraine
blood is love cook Gordon
he was 20 years old and he died on the
second day of the war on the 25th of
February
Russia's been so
reluctant to talk about their casualties
and you don't see these kinds of scenes
on Russian State TV
but the
have been so many kills
already in this one year of fighting
and it doesn't look like it's going to
end anytime soon
though the numbers are hard to verify
buriatia has one of the highest casualty
counts of any Russian region
not her real name has two nephews
fighting in Ukraine both try to
terminate their contracts she says and
they were turned down
um
living standards are low here
unemployment is high an army contract is
Big Money
nearly everyone has lost someone
um
foreign
used to attend the rally she could
against War then mobilization till they
were shut down 20
000 people detained in this one year of
War
why did you decide to speak out now
because this is dangerous for you
foreign
sometimes there are no answers just what
tomorrow brings another day in the
shadow of one man's War
and Diana joins me from Moscow and Diana
real contrast today at least between
Vladimir zielinski front and center of
his nation's marking of the anniversary
and Vladimir Putin frankly nowhere to be
seen
that's very true but Vladimir Putin was
all over the nation and the world's
television screens when President Biden
did his European tour perhaps not on the
first day when he arrived in thieve but
certainly when he was in Warsaw
President Putin gave his two-hour state
of the nation address and the next day
he held that huge rally in the main
Moscow stadium which was quite the
Patriotic spectacle and bear in mind too
that it is President Biden that Vladimir
Putin likes to consider himself
competing with rather than Vladimir
zielinski and it is the United States as
the sort of hegemon of the West that uh
Vladimir Putin claims that he is in
conflict with so I think that's why but
yes when you look at that Press
Conference held by Vladimir zielinski
and you bear in mind that last year
Vladimir Putin canceled his annual press
conference he only answered questions at
the end of the year to a very small
select bunch of Russian journalists he
absolutely does not want to be
challenged on his strategy on what he is
doing and I think that's why he's been
so controlled about it and all of the
speeches that he gave this week three
and all uh did not provide his people
with any kind of reassurance that this
war which he started a year ago
imagining that it would all be over fast
is going to end anytime soon and I think
there is a lot of concern here but there
is nothing that his people can do about
it all they have to do is fall behind
the fact that their president is
determined to go on
okay Diana thank you very much
well diplomacy has often felt sidelined
during the war gridlocked by the
combined power of Russia and China in
institutions like the UN at the United
Nations today the security Council saw
testy exchanges after the Ukrainian
foreign minister called for a minute
silence for the past Year's victims that
was interrupted by Russia's Ambassador
our U.S correspondent Mark Stone reports
on the world view of the war a world
Which is far from United
the Security Council is called to order
in the security Council chamber
Ukraine's foreign minister wanted to
remember the cost of the past year the
cost of Russia's invasion
I kindly ask everyone
to observe a minute of Silence in memory
of the victims of the aggression but
Russia's representative here interrupted
the silence he had another idea
and that is why we're rising to honor
the memory of them all
the Russian version of history is that
Ukraine started all this the minute
silence resumed he had successfully
seized the moment
they were in this chamber a year ago
exactly when Vladimir Putin in Moscow
chose to announce his move on Ukraine it
represented a total rejection of this
chamber this institution and the global
order it tries to preserve
and this anniversary was a chance to
count the cost
Putin cannot must not win in Ukraine
because what's at stake on the
battlefields
is the international order itself
if Russia stops fighting and leaves
Ukraine the war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting Ukraine ends
there is such symbolism to this place
the highest diplomatic body in the world
moments in here have changed history and
yet right now it does feel powerless
never mind the overwhelming rejection of
Russia and its actions in Thursday's
vote here Russia has a seat and the
power to block any initiatives that are
proposed the Chinese did present one a
12-point plan hardly a road map to peace
but an indication that they haven't
moved even closer to Russia first of all
I would like to thank you in your
Nations as the Western Alliance foreign
ministers spoke their leaders gathered
for a meeting of the G7 the outcome
bluntly was more words but nothing to
unlock a negotiation the message the
fighting cannot stop until Russia
withdraws
back in New York the shuttle diplomacy
for what it's worth continues in truth
though this day could only be about
reflection of a year that changed the
world because there is no projection for
what comes next we never give up we are
ukrainians
straight to New York then and mark the
reality is diplomacy is a bit of a
sideshow at the moment
obvious and depressing conclusion to
come to Mark what I would say though
against that is that it is calm careful
diplomacy among Western and Allied
Nations that has allowed for a a
remarkable level of unity against Russia
to be maintained countries across the
world demonstrated yesterday and again
today that they are largely United
against what Russia has done and that is
despite an extraordinary disinformation
campaign by the Russians over the course
of the past year here at the United
Nations uh in in capitals across the
world Russian diplomats trying to prize
other countries away and bring them
towards the Russian position that has
not worked but ultimately what can this
place do what can this Global World
Order that the U.N represents do to
change the position on the battlefield
the answer is nothing and the reason and
simply is because of the construct of
the United Nations because Russia has a
seat at that table because it has the
power of veto until that mechanism
changes and there's no mechanism that it
can allows it to change then nothing
will will change I spoke uh today this
afternoon to the Russian uh Deputy
Ambassador inside that building he
wouldn't appear on camera but I spoke to
him off camera and he said to me quite
clearly that the Russians are not going
to pull back the only thing that would
change what is happening on the ground
right now amounts to a capitulation by
the ukrainians and of course the
ukrainians will not do that
[Music]
Mark in New York thank you very much
indeed well from the moment of the
invasion the United Kingdom positioned
itself as one of Ukraine's staunchest
allies whether providing homes for
Ukrainian refugees sending Aid to those
who stayed behind or leading the push to
supply the country with ever more
powerful weapons today that solidarity
was on a full show skies in the man
Rasheed reports now on how the UK paid
tribute
thank you
[Music]
at 11 o'clock a minute silence
not for Wars gone by
but for a war of our time
it was less remembrance more solidarity
for a country that's faced a year of
brutal aggression
prime minister's past
and present
paid their respects as ukrainians who
now call Britain home prayed for an end
to this conflict
in the city of Bradford we met Olga
forced to leave her family and friends
she's now been living here for eight
months for many like her it's been a
year of pain it was a year of lost it
was year when you lost your home your
friends your life
and all of us try to find another
another place to live another friends
another people who can support us so
it's one year of our fight
and giving up simply isn't an option for
the Ukrainian Community with a deep
history in Bradford here hope and
strength over the last 12 months has
been needed more than ever
these are Yana's most recent memories of
Ukraine as she fled with her family
bombed buildings on their route out
there's no clearer reminder of War one
half of your mind living in Ukraine
every day she's been here now since
August last year she wants nothing less
than to return home one day you're just
like this
you didn't preparate yourself to all
this and when you when you go in you
don't know where to go and you don't
know what what's waiting you next day
and where you will be next day
and how you will survive this day give
them courage and resilience in battle
to make that happen Ukraine needs help
something Britain has been providing
since day one of this war today military
recruits receive training in the
Southeast even on this commemorative day
perhaps a sign there may be more
anniversaries to come into man Rashid
Sky News Bradford
I'll be back a little later in the
program but now let's go back to Jillian
in London
thank you
Sky News has learned that King Charles
was being lined up to play a key
ceremonial role in the final stages of
negotiations with the EU over Northern
Ireland the Monarch had been due to meet
the European commission's Ursula
vondeline tomorrow with the signing of a
new brexit deal expected imminently well
our Deputy political editor Sam Coates
is in Downing Street for us tonight and
Sam that the meeting has now been
abandoned but just how controversial
would it have been had it taken place
well if tomorrow's meeting between us of
underline and King Charles III had taken
place well one Royal official who's no
longer working for the palace said it
would have been deeply misguided another
senior Whitehall official who now at
student for government said it would
have actually profoundly changed the
rule of King Charles the III and and
here's why Jillian all this week on Sky
News we've been reporting that a brexit
deal to do with Northern Ireland has
been getting closer and closer it's now
hours if not just a day or two away and
even though number 10 has kept the
details Under Wraps we've been uh giving
you some of the Bare Bones of what's
likely to be agreed and it's very
controversial there are Tory brexiteers
there are many in the Democratic
unionists another unionist uh parties in
Northern Ireland who are likely to come
out in opposition of this deal it's
going to cause Division and yet here we
had the king meeting effectively the
chief negotiator of the rival team uh as
part of this process us tomorrow which
would have conferred an element as it
were of sort of Royal blessing on what
was going and of course the Charles King
Charles wouldn't have been taking part
in in negotiations but just those those
pictures on TV of Charles meeting uh
Ursula vanderline would have would have
suggested that there was uh Royal
approval for what was what was going on
yet the issue was deeply politically
controversial so thereby breaching one
of those profound parts of our Unwritten
Constitution which says that the
monarchy must be dragged into politics
now labor says this raises deep
questions about Rishi sunak who would
have been involved in the decision to
have tomorrow's meeting I think
unionists like uh Nigel Dodds the former
leader of the dup has raised questions
about whether or not this means the deal
is they're trying to have to sell try
too hard to have to sell uh this deal I
don't think tonight's Revelation by
skunies has made the job for number 10
any easier in the coming days okay Sam
thank you
police in Northern Ireland have
confirmed the shooting of a police
officer is terrorist related and the
main line of inquiry is the new Ira
detective Chief Inspector John Caldwell
was shot multiple times in Omar on
Wednesday night in front of his young
son and remains critically ill our
Island correspondent Stephen Murphy
reports from Omar
politics and policing United it's a rare
sight in a dark time Northern Ireland's
five main parties together to support
the chief constable and his wounded
colleague John Caldwell
John remains in hospital where he is
critically ill and heavily sedated last
night I had the chance to speak to
John's wife and his son
they are clearly heavily affected by
what they've gone through but want to
pass on their thanks both to the people
that rendered first aid in Care at the
scene but also in terms of the
outpouring of support from across the
community the first Minister designate
hailed a political Unity so often
lacking here it is so important and
moments like this that we stand United
and we do stand here United as one voice
in our condemnation against this
horrific attack on a police officer
there was a passionate denunciation of
violence from one leading unionist it
was an attack on our society it's an
attack on our children there's an attack
on our peace a hard one piece uh and
it's an attack on the Belfast Good
Friday agreement
but it will not work
the chief Constable admits that this
shooting has sent shockwaves through the
Police Service of Northern Ireland but
after visiting his officers in Oma last
night he said we are a tough and
resilient bunch
they'll need to be confirmation today
that this is a terrorist related
investigation with the new Ira the prime
suspects forensic teams in Omak continue
to examine the sports complex where
their colleague was shot multiple times
after a football training session shot
in front of his young son and many other
children something barely comprehensible
here
it's pointless senseless
I do that in front of children
it's Unforgivable
oh we don't want to go back to that time
again it's just unbelievable just to
stop it everybody's been talking to
completely disgusted and there's no room
for that anymore Omar is finding its
voice the community will gather for a
rally against violence tomorrow morning
their message to the men of violence the
men of yesterday is clear
Stephen Murphy Sky News
Junior doctors across England are to
strike for three days next month in
their ongoing dispute overpay the
British Medical Association says they
have no option but to walk out from the
13th of March having voted
overwhelmingly in favor of industrial
action earlier this month
rail workers represented by the tssa
union have voted to accept the latest
payoffers made by trained companies the
deals include a two-year pay rise worth
nine percent
three candidates were confirmed today to
replace Nicholas sturgeon as SNP leader
and Scotland's first minister they are
Scottish Finance secretary Kate Forbes
Health secretary hunza heussaff and Ash
Regan the former Community safety
Minister SMP members will be able to
vote for their choice next month
Margaret Thatcher's press secretary sir
Bernard Ingham has died at the age of
90. his family have announced the former
Fleet Street journalist for the guardian
served as baroness Thatcher's press
secretary for all but the first few
months of her Premiership
now so Rod Stewart is hardly known as a
shrinking violet but the singer today
told Sky News he wanted to prove he
wasn't all mouth and trousers after
calling a Sky News phone in to offer to
fund NHS scans he was as good as his
word my colleague Sarah Jane Mee went to
meet him
it's not quite a white horse but today a
night in his white Rolls is turning up
to do his bit for the NHS
[Music]
a man of his word sir Rod Stewart is at
his local hospital in Harlow Essex to
fulfill a pledge he made live on Sky
News
we have a caller now who's uh been
compelled to call us this afternoon
after watching from his home in
Hertfordshire it is Sir Rod Stewart so
Rod Stewart remind us why you called in
to speak to us at Sky News that day on
the day I spoke to you I just come back
from my scan in a private clinic in
Harley Street and I walked in I said I'm
terribly terribly sorry I'm half hour
late I said oh no it's okay we haven't
got anybody in here today there's eight
people there with the hardly anything to
do and then I thought this is a terrible
Injustice so here we are so Rod is
funding a mobile scanning unit at
princess Alexandra Hospital for the day
which means 20 people will have their
MRI scans and move off the NHS wait list
then come out and it's him
our start Starstruck what have I been
paying the last 40 years for you know I
mean it's cost me money to get this done
he shouldn't be having to subsidize it
to get to get the actual done mri's
going done things
um came to a halt in some ways in terms
of elective and planned
um Imaging activity over covid so
there's still quite a lot of uh there's
still a backlog of patients we're trying
to we're trying to get through plus the
new patients arriving on the waiting
list all the time on the day Junior
doctors decided to join NHS industrial
action so Rod Stewart says NHS staff
deserve more there must be enough money
in the coffers to play up for these
nurses only two years ago we were
clapping and now
listen they work so hard
so Rod Stewart with his own plan and
funding to help the NHS will the
government now follow suit but because
of your platform it created headlines
and you wouldn't make some noise right
you want to make some noise about the
state of the NHS absolutely I do and you
know I just don't want to do it here if
this is a big success because I think it
will be a night to do in in Belfast
Dublin Edinburgh Glasgow Manchester and
just keep it going I hope some other
people follow me because I want to prove
I am not all Mountain trousers
so let's do it talking to Sarah Jane me
there
now we've been hearing tonight about the
vast Injustice done to so many ordinary
people across Ukraine one of the darkest
names in this war is Butcher the scene
of a massacre in its early days butcher
was also the home of Tatiana sichkar a
46 year old mother until she was shot
dead while with her daughter I spoke to
her daughter also called Tatiana who
says her mother was just one more victim
of Russian war crimes
it happens somewhere here in the forest
on the outskirts of butcher tetiana
sichkar is telling me how a war crime
has devastated her life suddenly I heard
a very loud gunshot so something maybe
it was blood or maybe it was a bullet
she shows me a picture of her and her
mum
the most important woman in her life
and she explains what happened the day
they tried to walk home as Russian
troops occupied their streets and the
Woodland tracks nearby and that shot
rang out
I screamed laid down
and we all fall on the ground
I tried to shake her her leg she didn't
answer her head was all in blood there
was blood everywhere
uh her eyes were still open she was just
staring and I started to scream I
screamed for maybe five minutes where do
you think the shot came from my father
believed it because the Russians were
so
the sniper was on the second floor of
that white building behind the trees
Tatiana leads us to the grave of her
mother here it is
of course I miss the most her biggest
choice of course the closest one to me
but yeah that life's hard yeah but it's
hard but it's go goes on
do you think you will see the person who
did this in a court of law on trial it's
very likely that that person is already
dead but if that person is still alive
I believe that I will see him in the
court and he'll take all the
responsibilities and
maybe I'll ask him what made him do it
to my family
so now she is pursuing Justice regular
meetings with human rights lawyer Oksana
mikhailovich they want Ukrainian police
to Stage a reconstruction next month to
at least establish exactly where the
shot came from so they can perhaps
identify the Russian military unit
involved they will then go after the
commanders
I am sure there should be responsibility
for each crime says Oksana but I will
not stop because it is important Tatiana
says she owes it to her family to fight
she will not give up
one grave site one war crime one
destroyed life among so so many here
now president zielinski was asked at his
news conference today what was his
Darkest Day of the war so far he said it
was the day he went to Butcher and he
said this it was like the devil had
appeared on Earth the words of President
zielinski a year into this invasion